[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks everyone see ya my name's
Brant Hughes find me online it never
iasts in all the places and you know
this is a talk I've been thinking about
for a long time I actually came first
came up with like the original kernel of
an idea for this talk at this very
conference two years ago so I think it's
fitting that I'm able to actually give
it here at JSC confio
because this is a really special
conference I think we've all felt that
you know it's great technical content of
course you know some of the leading
technical content but really we're a
community more than that and so like as
you can probably guess I especially if
you ever read my Twitter bio I'm
bisexual polyamorous and bunch of other
stuff you can kind of go read there some
things that aren't at least in my bio I
was born in Texas in the United States
which was one of the most conservative
parts of the country so I grew up there
in the 80s and 90s so a little older
than I look
things were a little different back then
and so I'm gonna talk today about yeah
kind of queerness and tech and like how
these things sort of intersect in all
kinds of different ways because the
truth is it's complicated there's no
like binary tech is good Tech is bad or
anything like that it's it's just kind
of all over the map so I really want to
dig into what these things are really
like you know how tech helps how tech
hurts and how Tech can be better now I'm
just one person and you know we talk
about the queer community a lot but it's
not just one community there's not just
one type of person in it you know the
queer community is you know a federation
really there are lots and lots of
different communities with a lot of
different people a lot of different
experiences so of course disclaimer I
speak for myself I did reach out to a
number of other queer folks that I know
friends of friends things like that to
try and get a lot of different
perspectives as well though so you'll
see some quotes from other folks in this
so then hopefully at least not just
speaking for myself before we get into
it this talk does come with some content
warnings as I'm sure you can imagine
so if you need these parts of this talk
are difficult or uncomfortable for you
please take care of yourself feel free
to step outside anything like that so I
want to start by setting the stage a
little bit and go back and time a little
bit talk about one of the fathers of
computer science that Alan Turing he
made in numeral like contributions to
both computer science as well as
artificial intelligence you know the
sort of Renaissance were seeing right
now in tech you know artificial
intelligence the big new thing like Alan
Turing was talking about it in the first
half of the 20th century and Alan Turing
was also gay and he was persecuted for
it
I think in a way it's fitting that we
start by talking about tech and Korea
employees given in a way Alan Turing was
kind of the first queer tech employee at
least that we know of and so when we
talk about being a queer employee like
Tech is very complicated you know I'm
queer and I'm a tech employee I think a
lot of folks in this audience here are
and so it's really complicated like the
first thing I want to talk about like
one of the best things is that Tech
offers us stable employment and it's
career folks this is really important
because a lot of queer folks are just
not financially stable regardless of the
family we come from so many were you
know kicked out of their homes when they
were young so even if there was wealth
in the family that often didn't
translate to the queer kids themselves
and so like having financial stability
is important and with tech if we compare
to other professions that pay about the
same and offer the same stability Tech
tends to be one of the most accepting at
least in that strata of professions as a
queer tech worker I have a job that is
intellectually challenging and offers
economic stability I do my best to pay
it forward and pass that money along to
people who need it well the first issues
though that we tend to run into and this
is kind of a meta one is corporate pride
is rainbow capitalism all right I've
throughout I think about three different
definitions that you said let's break
this down a little bit so first the
concept of pride in the queer community
that's really really important to us
because for centuries in millenia we
were told that who we are is something
to be ashamed of it's not and it's taken
a lot of work for us to become proud of
who we are and so pride is very very
important to us and we're starting to
see a lot of companies expressing queer
pride in various different ways and so
this corporate pride is kind of it's a
new thing of course but we really look
at it though it's what we call rainbow
capitalism it's a rainbow capitalism is
whenever company
institution to whoever engages with the
queer Q not to help the queer community
but in order to further their own
interest usually to sell more products
make more money and what we end up
seeing is that corporate pride ends up
being just another reflection and lens
of rainbow capitalism the tech industry
is engaging in a queer specific version
of diversity theatre by sponsoring
events like the Pride Parade they market
themselves as queer friendly to improve
their brand and sell more products and
most of them are not doing anything to
make the life better for queer people
queer er G's which are employee resource
groups should be run by queer employees
however it's also important that you
value the work people are putting into
this I was the head of the queer
employee resource group for a while and
now at work was seen as completely
extracurricular and I missed out on a
promotion as a result see companies want
to take the work they do in order to
further their own interest and they
don't actually give that they don't
support us in that they only take it
from us and our other intersections are
compounded when we talk about social
justice we talk a lot about
intersectionality and that absolutely
applies to queerness as well and one of
the things that I think is important to
note about this is you know we tend to
think about diversity inclusivity as
like different axes and this is not
necessarily wrong but these axes are not
independent this is something we have to
remember when people will have more than
one marginalization they're dealing with
this is not an additive operation this
is a multiplicative one and they inform
each other and they influence each other
and that makes things a lot more
complicated when my disability became
ongoing it was hard to tell whether I
was being put on smaller projects
because of my disability gender or
actual job performance I'm definitely
more marginalized for my Judaism in ADHD
but that's only because I've been
working in queer friendly cities I'm
marginalized for both my queerness and
my race
career writes isn't an equal playing
field race always has something to do
with it our pain is ignored and
dismissed
just after the pulse nightclub shootings
I mentioned to a co-worker that I was
going to hold a moment of silence at an
upcoming all-hands my coworker said I
don't think tech companies should take a
stance on that kind of thing I like the
idea of being neutral like what the
I didn't say anything because I didn't
feel safe to speak up to this person who
thinks that company shouldn't condemn
gun violence against queer people of
color Tech is never neutral and the only
way you can actually think that Tech is
neutral if you live in a position of
extreme privilege but Tech is a part of
this world it always has been
[Applause]
and it shapes this world in a way that
no industry does in this day and age and
you know actually I should say something
else on this so I like I actually have
my own story with pulse as well I had
been working at Microsoft I think about
three four months I was working on a
product team before I got into my
current role now and pulse nightclub
sweeping shooting happened on a weekend
and I think every queer person remembers
that we can pretty clearly at least if
you're connected to the queer community
at that time and I was working on a
remote team something I'm very grateful
for in retrospect but we had a stand-up
Monday morning and I'm devastated of
course by every queer person that I know
every queer should I had talked to you
was to complete another wreck so I hop
on our call you know this is a virtual
call thankfully no video and like I'm
barely able to speak and everyone else
on my team all-district men by the way
they were just asking about each other's
weekends they were laughing and joking
like as if nothing had happened and like
I'm are I'm struggling so much already
and that made me feel so much more alone
in that moment because it was a reminder
that you know most people aren't queer
most people don't have to deal with that
and also you don't care so what can
Tekken players do first let's talk about
hiring and this is just a few things
like we could spend an entire talk on
this alone those give you a couple of
things first of all is ignore social
media like if you're hiring just don't
even look at a person social media
account because the truth is if we're
gonna talk about our daily lives that
means talking about things that some
people will find controversial and if
we're not gonna talk about our daily
lives you know the way that privilege
straight this white folks do then like
we get punished in ways they don't or we
have to hide it which is effectively
going back in the closet but then if we
talk about other marginalization on top
of it it gets even worse it's like again
if you look at my bio you know I'm on
Twitter I mentioned that I'm bi and poly
and I tried to be out about that but you
know what if
by queer woman especially of color said
the same thing that would probably
disqualify them from being hired but not
me the other thing is to understand
variances in employment history this is
especially true for trans folks because
the truth of the matter is that queer
folks in general have a tougher time
finding employment just their more
issues we have to deal with and the more
marginalize the more intersections are
the more difficult it is you know one
people find themselves in really bad
situations at work they get
discriminated and have to leave and so
especially the more marginalized folks
in the trans community tend to hop
around jobs a lot it's not the fault of
the queer person it's the fault of the
companies but in hiring they get
punished the queer person gets punished
for it
all the same so we need to understand
that and stop looking at that so then we
can talk about HR once people are
actually you know in the company you
know implicit bias training this is kind
of an obvious one and there are a lot of
problems with current implicit bias
trainings but this is still important
you know we all have biases this is the
nature of the human condition every
single person has some biases you know
we can't understand everyone's viewpoint
in the world
we didn't simultaneously grow up in
every single country to simultaneously
being porn to you know dozens of
different types of parents like we
cannot understand everyone's position
innately because we just don't have
those experiences and the best way we
can get through that is through
education and of course also we need to
improve implicit bias training and also
we need to take sexual harassment and
assault claims seriously this is
especially true for queer women because
this is an issue in the industry for all
women but again intersectionality this
comes into play for queer women face
even more issues there was a Remora
study came out a while ago that showed
that liked by women actually face more
discrimination than lesbian or straight
women as it turns out and there's whole
complicated host of reasons for that but
it's true and so taking these claims
seriously benefits queer people
especially and people of color and other
intersections as well
inclusion you know gender-neutral
language and bathrooms and we have
gender-neutral bathrooms here at this
conference and you know this is actually
part of the venue right they didn't do
that last-minute switch that a lot of
conferences do like you can do it at a
concert venue you can do it at work a
same thing with language you know don't
use heat him and document and
documentation stuff like that and of
course depending on the language this is
a little different some languages it's
easier to do gender-neutral pronouns and
others but you know regardless of the
language figure out what is the queer
community talking about in that language
and in that culture and figure out how
to support them with language preferred
names and pronouns and this is
especially important in companies that
this cup so that comes up in a lot of
places we don't think about you know
unfortunately for legal reasons most
companies have to have your legal name
but a person's especially a queer chance
persons their legal name is often not
their real name and we want to make sure
that we understand that and we propagate
that through a system so you know if you
have you know HR websites to log in to
look at your benefits make sure you're
showing their preferred name they're not
their legal name in your email you know
we all have like your email at corporate
email account make sure that that shows
your preferred name not your legal name
and someone who's so forth create queer
only
spaces you know I bet a lot of us use
slack it work so make sure that in those
slacks there's a queer only space and
the same thing for other marginalization
is by the way we need space to talk
amongst ourselves where we're not having
to constantly do one-on-one education
and of course let queer people speak and
listen stop speaking for us in thinking
that you know what is best for queer
people at your company so let's back out
and talk about tech in the broader queer
community so this is actually one of the
biggest benefits of tech comes into play
this is one of the most transformational
ones that I've seen is that tech enables
us to escape our isolation if this is
one of the biggest differences I've seen
from when I was a kid to when I was in
college because when I was a kid there
was no internet and even when I was in
high school it wasn't really there but
now we can actually find community
online and this is deeply powerful tech
makes it easier to find in the community
Grindr fetlife etc make finding
like-minded people
or people with the same sexuality a lot
easier than flagging and asking about my
friend Dorothy well if you don't know
that reference there's a reason
go read up on it Tech makes it easier to
find porn which helps with sexuality
discovery this is actually really
important I mean this is something that
a lot of folks don't think about but you
know when we grow up in a society that
tells us we're supposed to have certain
a certain orientation you know certain
sexual desires we have to dispel with
that we have to figure something else
and interesting enough porn is actually
a really good way to do that and this is
a male porn is tied into tech so we need
to this is so useful in so many ways
queer folks spend most of our lives in
some form of social isolation due to the
hostility and violence of the Syst
heteronormative society we are forced to
live in so having to provide a space for
all of us to be ourselves and meet
people like us matters Tech has allowed
isolated people to find thousands or
millions of others just like themselves
queer folks of all stripes have found a
large receptive community to help them
feel normalized and legitimate the trans
rights movement has proceeded so quickly
in part due to the ability of isolated
trans people being able to find a
multitude appears going through the same
process but tech asserts its biases on
the world I think the biggest harm is
training AI systems that incorporate
existing bias and then treating those
systems as Oracle's and always correct
also unlike with human interactions
where you can negotiate if a tech
solution is encoded to do something
there's no way to do it you know if
you're a queer non-binary or trans
person going to sign up for a service
and they only have a male/female radio
check button you know you can't talk to
the website and have that extra tech
button up here it's just not there you
can't do it a sec raishin is often
driven by powerful sis head men their
worldview is then baked into the tech
they create which has been spread
throughout the world via the internet
the internet now shapes our culture and
often it is a small portion of the
straight world who is setting
that culture tech is also complicit in
gentrification now gentrification is a
complicated topic and there's not just
one single cause but tech absolutely
does play a role in it societally some
of the safest faces for queer
communities are in big cities like New
York San Francisco and yes here in
Berlin
however tech is hyper gentrifying those
areas making it possible for most queer
folks to live and when queer folks can't
live in places that are safe for them
that means they have to move to places
that are not safe for them I live in San
Francisco so my local community pretty
much got destroyed by gentrification
along with everything else that's good
and beautiful and I live in San
Francisco and I have to agree
social media tech refuses to fix hate
and bullying online spaces have been
increasingly hostile towards
marginalized groups speaking up about
their oppressions and that's pretty
shitty like I've seen this a
couple of times myself friends friends
of friends where they are being harassed
by white supremacists on Twitter but
then they stand up for themselves Tech
doesn't come in and ban the Nazis they
ban the queer person standing up for
themselves I've seen this many times the
tech industry is profiting from social
media platforms that enable harassment
of queer and trans people as well as
spreading fascist ideologies the tech
industry has the power and resources to
quarantine harassment and hate speech
because we do it with spam and email
it's just that harassment hate speech
don't affect the white men in charge of
the industry the harm of viral Ness is
intersectional you know I think we've
all heard various stories in the media
about someone does something say is
something whatever it goes viral and
then their lives are ruined this is
compounded by intersectionality there's
a lot of stories I can tell there's
actually a very specific story I want to
tell though about two months ago a trans
black woman in Dallas my hometown I grew
up in Dallas you know I'm going
with this her name is Malaysia Booker
and she was assaulted in a parking lot
someone recorded it and it went viral
after the attack she had this to say
this time I can stand before you after I
was attacked whereas in other scenarios
we are at a memorial
so what can tech companies do the first
is safety and start by banning the Nazis
get rid of real name policies like
Facebook still has a real name policy
and I use finger quotes because these
are not people's real names they're
they're legal names and I've seen this
abused in many ways you know trans
people are banned from Twitter because
they dare to use their real name
and speak out against anti queer
legislation we're seeing more and more
anti queers legislation hopping up in
the United States here in Europe and
around the world and there is precedent
for this by the way here are two ago in
the United States when some of the
really bad anti immigration policy was
first being forced through you know
Microsoft released statements condemning
that we should do that with anti queer
legislation to and again ban the
Nazis it's 2019 why are we having this
conversation again and respect stop
using us as props to promote yourselves
we are not things in your game and put
your money where your mouth is companies
will spend tens of thousands of dollars
on one float in one Pride Parade yes
they actually cost that much but you
know what they don't give a single
dollar to any nonprofit that actually
helps queer people they only want to
look at they don't give a about us
so like where will the future take us
and you know this is something I'm torn
on myself like I don't know where we're
gonna end up and all of this
some days I'm pessimistic some days I'm
hopeful and today I'm gonna choose to be
hopeful though I want to read to you
some excerpts from a speech from some
time ago actually by Harvey Milk who was
a famous queer activist and I think you
had a lot of really good things to say
like every other group we must be judged
by our leaders and by those who are
themselves gay those who are visible for
invisible we remain in limbo a myth a
person with no parents no brothers no
sisters no friends who are straight no
important positions in employment
the anger and the frustrations that some
of us feel is because we are
misunderstood and friends can't feel the
anger and frustration they can sense it
in us but they can't feel it because a
friend has never gone through what is
known as coming out I will never forget
what it was like coming out and having
nobody to look up toward I remember the
lack of hope our friends can't fulfill
it I can't forget the looks on faces of
people who've lost hope be they gay be
they seniors be they black folks looking
for an almost impossible job be the
Latinos trying to explain their problems
and aspirations in a tongue that's
foreign to them I used the word I
because I'm proud I stand here tonight
in front of my gay sisters brothers and
Friends because I'm proud of you
San Francisco three days before Gay
Pride Day a person was killed just
because he was gay and that night I
walked among the sad and the frustrated
at City Hall in San Francisco and later
that night as they lit candles on Castro
Street and stood in silence reaching out
for some symbolic thing that would give
them hope these were strong people these
faces I knew from the shop the streets
meetings and people who I never saw
before but I knew they were strong but
even they needed hope and the young gay
people in the Altoona Pennsylvania and
the Richmond minnesota's who are coming
out and here Anita Bryant on television
in her story the only thing they have to
Ford to look to is hope and you have to
give them hope hope for a better world
hope for a better tomorrow hope for a
better place to come to you if the
pressures at home are too great hope
that all will be alright so without hope
not only gays with blacks Asians seniors
the handicapped the
says yeses will give up so if there's a
message I have to give is that I found
one overriding thing about my personal
election is the fact that if a gay
person can be elected it's a green light
in you and you and you you have to give
them hope
thank you
[Music]